uh record y recording okay my name is
Willow my name is Kayden and this is our
No Beats Workshop uh no be tosses
Workshop so first thing we covered is
the physics of a no beat one or standard
just
simply having a beat Letting Go the
purpose of this is to be as minimal as
possible this is a really nice Point
practice because it practices
relinquishing as much of the control of
our point to gravity as possible notice
for about half the circle not even
touching it right so that's a really
good exercise especially doing this with
both
hands anytime you pick up your PO it's
really good to do this if you're a
minimalist spinner who likes to have
very little force on your poy nice thing
to do is to take those moments where you
have threee hands try to touch your
body y touch your chest your
head touch your
friend and uh yeah see then we covered
the different types of tosses there's
this sort of backwards toss notice the
trajectory is going quite backwards and
the catch is Penguin Style so the arm
goes back elbow straight the Palm facing
up then there's these forward style
tosses where you come up under armpit
our favorite is definitely where you
slap down on it with your palm down
order to catch it but there's also two
other types one is open
Palm this is sur's version the other is
over the back of the hand and landing in
Reverse
SC okay those different types of tosses
have a lot of different
possibilities uh first thing we started
covering was simply going split same on
the wheel plane doing either those
backward
tosses or those forward
tosses looking at the different types
and trying them out so playing with both
of those on a variety of planes uh the
reverse one and split opposite the wall
plane here can also be done behind you
so both of these are wall
plan we'll have forward wall plane this
is called the doggy paddle This is
called the doggy paddle and
uh and you have that behind your body on
the wall plane as
well there's a nice exercise a plane
bending exercise that will get you
through all of those different
permutations of those tosses so he's
going that forward style toss starting M
his body bending until he gets in front
of his body doing the doggy paddle he'll
transition to those tosses which is
reverse style behind his back and then
he'll bend it till it's in front of his
body that'll take you through all of
them okay and then we started talking
about sort of split op land on the wall
plane doing these split op Novi tosses
has all kinds of possibilities there's
various different body
spaces talk about it sure uh the first
one we looked at was behind the head
froze like so uh the most important part
thereof is the catching position which
is your thumb pointed towards the ground
it lands you in a reverse drip but due
to the nature of No Beats it'll be
quickly Modified by you making another
throw and
catching uh we also dealt with under the
legs in No Beats wall
plane as well as behind the
back and over the shoulder as seen in
the forward Style no
beat
for this brings us into bring building
patterns these uh some of the patterns
we covered was behind in front behind in
behind front and front also known as a
211 112
112 we have a Convention of numbering
different body spaces that helps kind of
communicate these different patterns so
if you're interested in it just send us
a message this is 112 then we have like
uh
head uh we also went over Willow's
favorite is
the 627 726 726 hardest one I've been
able to find that's why I practiced it
oh wait how do I do
this remember it
now last
time remember
it secret it's a
mystery there we
go there it
is you'll find a lot ofos we also win
over crossers and some other wheel plane
goodness
so how it fundamentally works is arms
are crossed just like we would a Crosser
and at any point the hand is on the
bottom we throw don't you throw catched
as the hand moves to the top you can
repeat that process with both
hands when you do it
consistently uh becomes this move here
so then we didn't go over earlier is
something we we affectionally call West
pedon mode which is where you throw from
the top and catch on the bottom
which is way harder and also very
cool and uh this is definitely really
fun to do in L off as
well get a lot of out of doing it split
up uh there're also the wall plane
versions of the
crossers uh so same thing the only thing
difference here is his planes are going
to be bent a little bit to make it
possible um and notice that he's
spinning inwards on the top
that's the better version of it outward
is also possible it's just a little bit
more wonky uh yeah we cover okay we
covered how to learn weaves there's a
lot of them uh but the best method is
just to take that first thing we started
with send one over and catch underneath
the other arm then come back to the
neutral
position doing this weave where you go
one side neutral position then other
side is the first one to start with both
in forwards and
backwards then eventually you can start
incorporating behind the back weaves
which there are technically all the same
that you would do normally um but in no
be
weaves and a couple more nuggets uh
although there's a lot more only what we
covered in the work was transitions what
transitions oh transitions oh the
transitions there's the four styles on
the wall plane if you're spinning is
same there's this one where you're
spinning under the
armpits uh doing that forward style toss
and then tossing under the armpit with
the other hand second one would be kind
of the same thing except no armpit
toss third one would be
catching underneath the other arm with
the neutral toss and then making that
catch into a penguin
catch so you have the choice anytime
you're spinning uh doing no be tosses to
use those transition points and then
doing so if you want to just say turn
from one side to the
other and you can go through any one of
those
modes or you can go through all four of
those modes or any combination of them
yes it's pretty cool you also do the
maximally awkward uh under the armpit
with penguin
catch I kind of hate but you might not
so go for it um
other so of the Nuggets we went over
first nugget we went over two just a
quick two
hands uh
toss
[Music]
toss way to learn that is to go
through once at a time until it starts
to get smooth and
comfortable it's slowly increasing your
numbers one
two
um we also went over the Funky Chicken
which is funky chicken is really hard
it's that motion right here in order to
drive it you have to move your shoulders
nice little concentric
circles FY chicken someone else please
do that please learn it that' be' be
good then we can high five oh yeah high
five
five got like yeah so goal basically as
an overarching statement like noi tosses
is to we usually try to just spin like
normal flowing moving doing things um
and with the added challenge of just
making every toss no toss want to be
able to move around at our
Leisure explore different hand positions
Etc all well doing no be tosses that's
something to try so as you practice
these you become more affluent start
trying to move around and uh
incorporating them into your flow that's
what it's all about yes I'm quite fond
of the phrase 50 50%
handsfree that's how I how I sum up
here toes that's our
workshop for the
[Applause]
win